Two Problems: Regular Expressions for Revolutionaries
Sarah Saltrick Meyer
[Applause]
SARAH: Hi guys, thank you so much for the
warm welcome.
JSConf really is a conference among conferences
and it's really a pleasure to be here.
So the name of this talk is: Two Problems.
It is in fact to talk about regular expressions,
if regular expressions are something that
scare you please take a seat and sit down,
this talk is for you.
If regular expressions are something you love
and feel very comfortable with, also this
talk is for you.
So who am I?
My name is Sarah Saltrick Meyer and I'm a
web developer based out of New York and I
work for a company called Buzz feed again
doing web dev.
So there's a real classic and wonderful joke
about web expressions.
Some people when confronted with a problem
think: I know, I will use regular expressions.
Now they have two problems.
You may have heard this joke from the person
sitting next to you at your first job, that's
certainly when I first heard it, but the actual
source of the quote is a guy named Jamie Zawinski
on a group in 1997 and Jamie was an Emacs
devotee, approaching the status of a religion
for him apparently, and he hated Perl with
a passion.
One of his other really meaty quotes is: Perl
combines the power of C with the readability
of PostScript.
So clearly a man of strong opinions and pithy
statements.
Why would he say this?
Regular expressions are a great tool, aren't
they?
You can use them in a HTML input box to validate
the form of input.
Obviously you use them all the time when you
are trying to match an pattern in text.
I've seen websites ... but why would regular
expressions be a problem?
I rather think it's because of things like
this.
Can you all actually read this here?
Use your hand if you can read it.
Okay, okay, so does anyone recognise this
nasty scrum of characters and numbers?
US phone number, thank you!
And wow, it's just gross, isn't it?
It's just nasty, looks like something you
would pick off the bottom of your shoe programming-wise,
and so the reason I think that people - regular
expressions are a problem even as they solve
problems for us is this lack of comprehensibility.
When I need a regular expression at work,
I Google it, so I would just Google regular
expression for a phone number and take that
top Stack Overflow answer and probably most
people would do the same, but regular expressions
are something more than just something that
we, you know, can take somebody else's advice
for.
They are more than something where you find
the experienced senior dev in the room, or
maybe the one person who you know is a regex
whizz and you go ask them for it.
They can also be something like this.
So I totally stole this beautiful graph from
JavaScript [inaudible], a classic, and this
is a description of the various ways that
white space can be evaluated that code can
sort of not be evaluated within JavaScript,
and let's run through them [sound problem]
... here.
Obviously a space will just be a space.
A tab will just be evaluated as a tab, and
a line end similarly, nothing will happen.
But then we get down into here, so if the
parser is running and hits a forward slash,
well then, if it sees another forward slash
and then it sees any character except for
a line end, and it can seen any numbers, so
what is that?
Of course, it's a comment, yes.
Then it gets a little bit more complicated,
of course, for our beautiful multiline comment.
We have the forward slash, we have an asterisk,
ooh, and then I can optionally - you see it's
not on the path here - I can optionally have
another forward slash but then I have to have
any character except the slash and the asterisk,
and I can have as many of those as I want.
But I have to finish off with another asterisk
before my final forward slash, and the real
meaning of this diagram here is that you cannot
- you can have slashes and asterisks within
your comment but if you have a slash and then
an asterisk, you've closed the comment.
And you are done.
So, gosh, well what does this have to do with
regular expressions?
This is a regular expression I wrote for you
guys very specially.
It really broke my brain, it felt like a test
in school because I did actually used to do
this at school, I would have a regular diagram
like that and have to turn it into a regular
expression, not with Perl syntax though, this
is Perl syntax which of course is also used
in JavaScript.
Without going into it too much, we have the
simple cases, we have a space here, a tab,
ooh and then it starts to get clicked.
We have these escaped slashes and then line
ends, and then this incredibly nasty thing
is the - you can have asterisks and slashes
but they can't be next to each other unless
you are closing out.
So, what exactly is a regular expression,
my gosh?
They were defined in the 1950s before there
was such a thing as an automatic computer
really.
So they pre-date the actual machines that
we could our work on and they were defined
by a wonderful guy named Stephen Culchrane
who you love even if you don't know who he
is because he is responsible for this little
star, the clean star, which you probably use
all the time.
The clean star is not part of regular expressions
per se; it's rather, I would say, a notation
that we very frequently use in regular expressions
and probably the most commonly used of all
pattern matchers is: tick everything, star.
Yes, I love this very much.
I think it's very pretty and also useful.
So what exactly makes a regular expression?
It's a set of characters that describe other
characters with origins in the attempt to
describe natural language in a computable
way.
So we have that pipe.
We have the concept of grouping, the notion
that if I have ABCD, or AXYD then that is
equivalent to ABC or XYD; and then lastly,
quantification.
This syntax may be familiar to you, the question
mark is I believe 01, the star is of course
0 pipe, and the plus is 11 or more.
So we've got all that.
We kind of know what we are talking about
here, but let's try to place regular expressions
in sort of a wider world of concepts, a wider
world of attempts to describe language, and
actually we think of ourselves as web developers,
we do code, but code is language and it is
specifically an attempt to translate human
language into language that computers can
understand, and regular expressions are just
one in a whole set of toolboxes for doing
this, and they were described by this gentleman,
who may be familiar to you, this is Noam Chomsky,
who in addition to his wonderful political
opinions also is responsible for the Chomsky
Hierarchy of Grammars so as you can see regular
expressions are down here, the most limited
subset of the Noam Chomsky hierarchy and then
we work air way up through the context free
and others, so what are these?
Actually the type zero unrestricted grammar
is something that you are also all familiar
with and I say I am familiar with these machines
in the same way as regular expressions - I'm
certainly not an expert, I just know they
help me do the things I need to do.
What exactly is a Turing machine?
This is a Turing machine that somebody built
with Lego.
It has wheels and goes back and forth.
We have a beautiful quote which I am going
to read out: a Turing machine is an unlimited
memory capacity obtained in the form of an
infinite tape marked out onto squares on each
of which a symbol could be printed.
At any moment there is one symbol in the machine,
it is called the scan symbol.
The machine can alter the scan symbol and
its behaviour is in part determined by that
symbol but the symbols on the tape elsewhere
do not affect the behaviour of the machine.
However, the tape can be moved back and forth,
this being one of the elementary operations
of the machine.
Any symbol on the tape may therefore eventually
have an innings.
That is a quote from Alan Turing, I think
in addition to being a brilliant computer
scientist and truly the father of the industry
that we work in now, he was a lovely writer
as well.
So Alan Turing, of course, committed suicide
after he began to be persecuted by the British
Government for being gay, and I think there's
a lot of irony in the fact that a man who
contributed so much to our understanding of
patterns and communication literally died
for not fitting a pattern that was prescribed
by the society that he lived in.
Well, moving right along, type 1 grammars,
they are boring.
I don't really understand what the use case
is for them.
It seems to be mostly theoretical.
But they are called context-sensitive because
they come with a little bit of context.
So I don't know them, I don't know her.
The type 2 grammars on the other hand, I'm
not going to read out all this math, it comes
from Wikipedia, I do encourage you to look
this up, but most programming languages are
interpreted by computers as type 2 languages
so as we are moving up this hierarchy here.
And type 2 has something extremely important,
type 2 languages have a stack.
So you will note that in a regular - of course,
in a regular expression there's no concept
of memory.
You are only - you don't know, as you are
matching that pattern, the things that you've
seen before but once you have the introduction
of a stack you can keep track of the past
and use it to help you evaluate the current
input.
Then type 3 grammars are irregular expressions
and they are equivalent to finite-state automata
which is something else you may have used,
perhaps a finite-state machine library for
some context at work so regular expressions
are mathematically equivalent, they can always
be translated in between each other, and this
is a picture from my native city.
These are some turnstiles at a subway stop
in Harlem and subway turnstiles are actually
one of the classic examples of a finite-state
machine, and I will show you how.
So the way that a turnstile used to work,
now pretend that the coin is a Metro card
swipe, these coins are obsolete unfortunately,
if the machine is locked then no matter how
much you push, nothing will happen.
You return to the locked state.
But if you put in a coin, then you are in
the unlocked state and no matter how many
coins you put in, it will still be unlocked,
you have done nothing to it.
I have actually done this, swiped my Metro
card accidentally multiple times, spending
$275 each time, very frustrating, but then
if you push through the turnstile, you return
to that locked state and you can only get
out of it again by putting in a coin.
So you could actually write a regular expression
for this where you represent where the coin
and push would be your letters, your characters
in it, and the locked and unlocked states
would be the potential states that you could
get to.
So one thing that you may have heard, it's
another thing that I heard sort of second
hand at my first job, is that you can't parse
HTML with a regular expression and the reason
for that is the same thing that I said about
the context free grammars, they have a stack,
right?
So to parse HTML we need that stack.
We need to put down the HTML tag and then
we need to put down the body tag and then
we need to put down our headers and build
up that stack and as we unparse or get to
the end of the execution, we start popping
those elements, author stack as we see their
closing tags, and that's how we get proper
HTML parsing, so that again because regular
expressions do not have a stack, do not have
a sense of memory, cannot be done with a true
regular expression.
But the regular expressions that you use in
programming languages like JavaScript which
takes its implementation from Perl, and Perl
I think has been the most significant influence
on the development of regular expressions
in sort of day-to-day programming - you know,
I personally, one of the very first things
I ever had to do that somebody paid me to
write code for was to write Perl scripts to
parse some documents and put them into a different
directory structure.
It's a good task for an intern actually.
You learn a lot.
So Perl expressions have features, those negative
look-aheads that make them no longer pure
regular expressions but capable of a wider
variety of tasks than true regular expressions
are.
So from that I have a quote from Larry Wall
who did create Perl so probably the worst
enemy of that Jamie guy I quoted earlier.
"The term has grown with the capabilities
of our pattern-matching engines, so I am not
going to fight linguistic necessity here."
A wise man.
"I will, however, call them regexes ..."
so what's the difference really?
Those regular expressions meet the criteria,
the deterministic criteria in particular it's
important to remember, that each of its transitions
is uniquely determined by its source state
and input symbol and reading an input symbol
is important for each transition; with the
power of modern regexes, has actually become
quite divorced from the underpinning of the
regular concept, lovely as those are.
So again a regex has only its state and a
Turing machine has memory, and regexes therefore
are appropriate for a sort of service level
parsing of information.
They are very useful and they help us a lot.
They still are only one tool for us and as
with many things, as with many things in programming,
right, a limit is not necessarily bad.
If you were using a limited set of tools,
you may see better performance because there
is less that it has to do, whereas so regexes
exist then in a very limited world that is
connected to a much broader world of computation
and of the attempt to let computers understand
humans, so there's a sort of a sad ending
to a lot of the attempts to describe human
language that many like Turing and Chomsky
were working on, and this was sort of the
post-war attempt to turn human language into
a set of rules that machines could understand
easily and the notion that we would be able
to find a theoretical description of all human
language.
I think as programmers you all know better
than anyone else that we are never going to
achieve that, right?
We are probably never going to write a programme
that deterministically understands human input.
This is actually, the rise of machine learning
and non-deterministic algorithms to parse
language is a recognition of the notion that
we don't have - we will never find a true
answer, a correct answer; we can only throw
a bunch of guesses at the wall and determine
which one is closest to our understanding
as humans.
So I will leave you with - there wasn't that
much JavaScript in this talk, right?
So it's right here.
This is about the implementation of other
expressions than JavaScript.
Of course you may declare a regular expression
in one of two ways, either with those lovely
backslashes or with the regex constructure
so the previous one is for a value that will
never change whereas if you want to construct
a regex dynamically and have it evaluated,
please use the constructor and enjoy writing
regular expressions in JavaScript.
I certainly do.
So here I have been thinking a lot about regular
expressions since making this talk.
I sort of have a vision of applications as
being modelled like that turnstile, of designers
making automata ... and then somehow turning
that into regular expression.
I don't know how that would look but it's
really cool.
They are also really good with games, so write
that with a regular expression.
I think you could also make some cool web
art [sound problem] ... obviously writing
a chatbot that's too obvious for words, but
a lot of us, because we are web developers
and eager to take any tool that works, we
- if we don't know about the theoretical underpinnings
of this they can remain very opaque and difficult
to understand.
I have a math background and still look at
the Wikipedia definition of these things and,
oh, it breaks my brain, but knowledge and
education is a treasure and knowing how things
work, even if it's not going to help you in
your day-to-day is, I think, something that
is very beautiful and very useful, and it
will enrich your understanding of what you
do on a day-to-day basis.
So seek out theory, and also don't blame other
people for not having knowledge of theory.
Get as much as you can and give as much to
other people, and I think that's the way to
be a truly effective programmer.
Thank you very much.
[Applause]